Німеччина не виключає постачання важких
бойових танків леопард що підтримати
українські військову майбутньому про це
заявив віце-канцлер ФРН Роберт габек в
інтерв'ю одному з німецьких телеканалів
коли настане це майбутнє щоправда
невідомо але зміна тональності свідчить
про позитивні зрушення в німецькому
уряді кажуть експерти напередодні Різдва
Франція США Німеччина пообіцяли Україні
нові поставки бронетехніки зокрема 40
бойових машин піхоти Мардер до кінця
цього кварталу
Мені здається що в нинішньому випадку з
мардером рішення прийняті сполученими
штатами Америки щодо поставки Бредлі і
рішення Франції щодо поставки
розвідувальних танків вплинули на
німецьке мислення тому я вважаю важливим
щоб не лише України а й інші партнери
України продовжували підштовхувати уряд
Німеччини до перегляду своєї позиції та
прийняття спільних рішень
тож яку броню техніку вже пообіцяв захід
і як вона може змінити хід війни
французький mx-10rc
це два в одному і танк і гармати на
колесах цю бронемашину використовують в
основному для бойової розвідки Вона
надзвичайно мобільна і Тиха Ось на якій
швидкості несеться
AMX 10 RC
завдяки колісному приводу та Малій вазі
цей повнопривідний розвідувальний танк
розганяється до 85 кілометрів на годину
Та може пересуватися на відстані до 800
кілометрів
це вдвічі далі звичайних гусеничних
танків при цьому він має доволі потужну
105-міліметрову гармату
mx10 RC навряд чи матиме шанси проти
звичайних танків броня значно слабша але
протистояти їм і не входить в його
завдання
16-тонний танк на колесах обслуговує
Екіпаж з чотирьох осіб його розробили Ще
б у 70-ті роки емікси 10rc добре себе
зарекомендував під час виконання бойових
місій у чаді і раку косав і Афганістані
та малі
американський Бредлі М2
Сполучені Штати нададуть Україні бойові
машини піхоти Бредлі М2 машину озброєна
25-міліметровою автоматичною гарматою і
кулеметом а також кількома бронебійними
керованими ракетами Бредлі М2
розрахована на підрозділ з 9-10
військових може переміщатися водою на
глибині до 1 метра 20 см і рухатися зі
швидкістю до 65 км/год його також можна
перевозити важкими транспортними
літаками Бредлі М2 разом зі стандартними
американськими основними бойовими
танками М1 Абрамс який Київ також
сподівається отримати призначені для
протистояння Танкам та піхоті противника
Абрамс завдяки кращій броні та міцнішим
озброєнню йде попереду А Бреді
забезпечує фланговий захист його
випускають із 80-х років і він став
одним із найбільш масових
бронетранспортерів у світі
які використовували у всіх великих
військових операціях США включаючи війну
в перській Затоці 1991 року та війну в
Іраку 2003 року
німецький Мардер
це бойова машина піхоти яка забезпечує
доставку піхоти та вогневу підтримку
Мардер може вмістити у собі шість-сім
бійців Він оснащений 20-міліметровою
автоматичною гарматою а також
опціонально керованими ракетами проти
наземних і повітряних цілей завдяки
водолазній гідравліці може рухатися
крізь воду глибиною до двох метрів на
озброєнні Мардер прийняли ще в 1971 році
модель пума яка мала прийти на заміну
виявилася досі настільки проблемною що
наразі не може замінити Мардер та Чи
вплине постачання цієї західної
бронетехніки на перебіг війни в Україні
якщо поглянути на цифри А США надають
близько півсотні Бредлі Німеччина
близько 40 мардарів це не та чисельність
яка потрібна Україні тобто кількість
змін Не принесе але це перші броньовані
бойові машини які надходять від Заходу
тож гадаються зміна важлива сама по собі
усе залежатиме від того де Україна
застосовуватиме Ці машини найімовірніше
на певних відрізках лінії фронту на яких
точаться запеклі бої і де вони дійсно
можуть щось змінити
Марк драми планується оснастити один
батальйон ЗСУ навчатимуть українців у
Німеччині експерти зазначають ця Техніка
не нова на озброєнні бундесверу мардари
стоять уже півстоліття але перевірена її
захисні характеристики багато в чому
перевершують радянські аналоги які
активно використовуються на війні Росії
проти України що відбулося чому саме
зараз Німеччина зважилася на поставки
БМП досі канцлер ФРН постійно
наголошував що Берлін не постачатиме
нічого не узгодивши попередньо свої дії
з партнерами тож обіцянки поставок
вітамінеля макрона і Джо байдена
вочевидь стали саме тим сигналом якого
чекали в Берліні офіційно ж в уряді ФРН
обґрунтовують своє рішення цілою низкою
факторів мовляв закінчується запаси
радянської техніки яку можна передати
Україні очікується розширення бойових
дій навесні та й обстріл інфраструктури
також вплинули на ухвалення цього
рішення
критики ж називають згоду на постачання
мардарів запізнілою адже за їхніми
словами більш ранні поставки врятувала б
чимало життів українців і країна могла б
звільнити на цей момент більше території
на тлі рішення щодо бмп-мардер дедалі
голосніше ми стають голоси тих хто
вимагає поставити Україні важкі бойові
танки саме ця техніка потрібна українцям
для прориву на фронті та повер території
за відправку танків леопард виступають
вже високопоставлені представники
правлячої коаліції
зупинятися на досягнутому щодо
бмп-мардер було б неправильно Нам треба
зробити все необхідне та поставити Все
що можна у тому числі танки леопард
партнери по коаліції з вільної
демократичної партії згодні з цим хоч і
нагадують подібний крок вимагає
узгодження з партнерами по НАТО було б
розумно поставити не лише Мардер а й
танки леопард важливо підтримувати
обороноздатність України однак у цьому
питанні Німеччина не повинна діяти сама
активно виступають за постачання танків
в Україні і в опозиційному блоці хдсхсс
на думку оглядачів разом із дискусією
про постачання важких танків наступні
місяці може бути порушене питання і про
постачання бойових винищувачів що швидше
Україна матиме ці види озброєння То
раніше зможе закінчити війну вигнавши
російські війська зі своєї території
стверджують експерти
територія України - це степ особливо на
півдні для того щоб досягти прориву на
фронті щоб витіснити росіян з
української території потрібно створити
механізовану силу особливо проти
супротивника які мають дуже сильну
артилерію Ось чому для цього поштовху
потрібна комбінація основних бойових
танків і бойових машин піхоти цю
нині Україна воює здебільшого
радянськими танками т-72 а також їхніми
модернізованими версіями які надала
Польща та Словаччина але сучасні бойові
танки зокрема німецьке леопард-2 та
американський Абрамс мають значно вищі
тактико-технічні характеристики і могли
б суттєво змінити ситуацію на користь
України експерти оптимістично
налаштовані що майбутній дискусіях буде
прийнято рішення поставити в Україну ще
й бойові танки
ще кілька днів тому мав позицію не
постачати сучасні бойові машини піхоти
але зараз ухвалили рішення про їхню
поставку тож навіть якщо є позиція поки
що не постачати танки Леопард 2 не
виключено що таке рішення ухвалять в
майбутньому і я вважаю що важливо завжди
зосереджуватися на військовій ситуації
на передовій в Україні та чітко
пояснювати що необхідно суто військової
точки зору Я стверджую що з військової
точки зору будуть необхідні основні
бойові танки
леопард два оснащений 120 міліметрової
гранатою яка дозволяє на ходу атакувати
нерухомі або рухомі цілі цей танк вагою
60 тонн і потужністю 1500 кінських сил
перебуває на озброєнні багатьох армій
світу і довів свою ефективність в
операціях в Афганістані перш за все
через високий рівень захисту від Атак